I get asked on a fairly regular basis
why I don't spend more time talking
about movies that I like so how about we
spend some time talking about a movie
that I am excited for detective Pikachu
now even though I am excited for
detective Pikachu I do want to try to
make this an objective review so here's
a short list of criteria that I've come
up with to grade the movie on first
laughs now I feel like the value of
having at least a couple good jokes in a
movie starring Ryan Reynolds is pretty
self-evident so I'm not going to expand
on this anymore
second adventure now I'm not expecting a
movie called detective Pikachu to be a
like deep dive into the darkest recesses
of the human psyche but I am hoping that
there's you know at least a fun
adventure with things that happen that
are exciting to look at third we're
gonna be rating this based on heartfelt
moments now while Pokemon is a franchise
can get some flack for being overly
sentimental in an error of growing media
cynicism we should probably at least
just a little bit more open to sincerity
and fourth hunter again like jokes I
feel the value of Hunter is self-evident
so I will not be expanding on this any
further now because this is an objective
rating system we give each a score out
of five and then apply a weighting
giving us a sum out of 100 can you tell
that I've worked in curriculum
development before this rubric right
here
flawless bullet proof academic oversight
would have no notes and zero revisions
but anyway that's the system that we're
gonna be using so now I just need to go
see detective Pikachu
[Music]
all right so the first questions it's
gonna be on everybody's minds how much
did they pander to the perverts and the
answer is very little I didn't see a
single Gardevoir but with that out of
the way let's get to the actual numbers
okay
so first up was it funny yeah actually
this was pretty funny movie I I got a
few good chuckles out of me and I was
really Amy you're just going ham on that
toy mouse
so yeah the movie was decently funny got
a few good laughs out of me I'm glad we
saw in a fairly full theater with like a
diverse crowd of Ages because it really
kind of helped contextualize a lot of
stuff so there's a few jokes that like
for me didn't work but they played like
really well with the kids so I you know
it's it's it's broad it's gonna it's
gonna hit kind of all age ranges there's
probably gonna be a joke in there that
you're gonna find it's a little bit
funny I mean unless you just unless
you're going in to just be a hater and I
mean yeah a lot of it's cheesy but I
mean embrace it embrace the cheese so
for this I'm actually gonna give it a
five because it if it fulfilled kind of
all the requirements it had a lot of
jokes who was consistently funny
throughout it wasn't just like RKO
whether it was like two funny scenes it
was fairly funny it was consistently
funny throughout and it was funny in a
way that would appeal to a wide group
wide audience and the jokes aren't just
the purview of Ryan Reynolds the entire
cast has really good comedic chemistry
and everybody gets you know at least one
solid line
next up adventure so for this I'm
actually gonna give it a three out of
five because while you're going in
expecting the adventure itself the story
and the plot is gonna be fairly broad
and easy to understand so that like a
really young audience is going to be
able to keep up and follow
the whole thing kind of just gets a
little weird and messy at the end and
you know the the landing the landing is
really important to stick so it's it's
really it's good it carries you along at
a good pace keeps moving it's fun it's
interesting and then it just kind of
gets a little you know the it's not bad
but landing the the ending is very is
very important and since we're being
very objective here and we're dealing
with numbers and math and we're
establishing an objective numerical
value I'm gonna have to go I'm gonna
have to go with a three out of five
they're kind of to demonstrate why I'm
cutting back on the adventure score a
little bit I would point to there's a
big action set piece kind of in the late
middle of the movie like right before
the climax where the landscape is being
torn up and then all of this stuff is
going on and it's chaos and and then it
just kind of like ends and literally
undoes itself and there are consequences
and it does sort of move things forward
but it's a really really really big
landscape altering set piece that just
then goes away so it's exciting but it
doesn't build on anything so that's why
we're gonna we're shaving a bit off that
adventure score heartfelt moments aka
feels this one I'm gonna say like four
solid four you could probably I mean if
you argued with me enough maybe creep
that up to a five as well but I'm gonna
go with a four there are several scenes
that that managed to activate this want
this need this emotional response and
they're done sincerely they're not
played as a joke you know opening up to
others is
as good and valuable and it's a thing
that the characters need to learn to do
and they all grow a little bit and they
they are a little more emotionally
mature by by the end of the movie and
and I would say maybe the point comes
out just cuz it's it's a little it falls
a little too heavily on a few clichés
like it's a lot about you know it's it's
dead mom and and daddy issues and you
know it's a classic formula I guess but
it's also an overused formula so maybe
we'll shave off a little bit for that
and I gotta say fuels wise the scene
from the trailer where like the little
herd Bulbasaur's comes out yeah it's a
pretty damn cute movie last hunter there
are zero hunters in this movie but
there's a lot of Gengar and so for
Hunter I'm gonna go with a 1 out of 5
now if there would be both a gengar and
the ghastly I'd maybe go up to 2 now
it's not a zero a zero would be
absolutely nothing but the void left by
hunter is is felt palpably through the
entire movie like just down to its fiber
you sense the absence of Haunter and so
unfortunately one out of five alright so
if we add all this up objectively
mathematically speaking Pokemon
detective Pikachu gets a 26 out of 100 I
did enjoy this movie I had a really good
time beginning to end but unfortunately
numbers just don't lie
this means that mathematically detective
Pikachu is actually one of the worst
movies I've ever talked about on Mike
so one of the remaining outstanding
questions is does detective Pikachu
represent a changing of the wind for
video game movies so detective Pikachu
pokémon detective Pikachu is based on a
spin-off game from the Pokemon series
called
detective Pikachu now I want to say yes
but no but maybe but no Pokemon ends up
actually being it a little bit of a
different category from most of what we
would categorize as video game movies
because Pokemon itself was developed by
the Pokemon company from the get-go as a
multimedia franchise it was never really
intended to be just a video game or just
a card game or just an anime or just a
manga or you know what it was it was
always going to be all of these things
so it was designed from the ground up
with that in mind and there's a very
like distinct hierarchy within the
company about like the these sort of
supremacy of different sources and
there's a standard like operating Bible
that they all work from in order to
develop like the look and feel and sound
and they have voice actors who have been
working with specific characters and
like Pokemon voices the voices of
Pikachu thee the animal voice the
Pokemon voice of Pikachu has been the
same for 20 years now
you know there's there's a control there
in in how all of it's managed whereas
the vast majority of video game movies
that I tend to talk about on the channel
are our video games first that are then
being turned into a movie either by a
video game company that has no
experience making movies or by a
filmmaking company that has no
experience with video games
so the the particular alchemy that goes
into a video game movie to produce
something like The Legend of chun-li or
Super Mario Brothers or Street Fighter
it's it doesn't exist within Pokemon and
only within Pokemon just because of the
way that the franchise is structured and
if you think about it like Pokemon
already has like a dozen movies under
its belt as a franchise and yes those
are all the animated movies for which
are an extension of the television show
but that's not nothing
so while the text Pikachu is itself a
little bit more of a direct adaptation
in that like there's a specific spin-off
game that is being adapted name and
premise into this movie it it still
exists within the context of the Pokemon
style guide to the Pokemon hierarchy the
the central control of the Pokemon
company but seriously I can't stress it
enough this this movie it's super cute
like even even the weird creepy like
deliberately creepy unsettling Pokemon
are still cute I forgot to record a
conclusion last night so I'll just say
like I actually really enjoyed this
movie I had a good time it was it was a
lot of laughs it was a lot of fun it was
touching it was you know it was good
it's a good movie but there's no Haunter